your value is not tied to your work so
you have to learn to separate those two
I give you a real life example early in
my career I was assigned to work with
somebody who I'd never worked with
before and he had a reputation of being
let's call him tough so I went and wrote
a PowerPoint presentation and I brought
it to him and he went through it with a
red pen and I thought it was pretty good
work but it was brutal so I went back to
my desk and I did it again gave it to
him and he went through it again Brutal
by about the fourth time I was sort of
weirdly having fun I said come on it's
not as bad as you're making it out to be
but I had a sense of humor about it net
net I did seven rounds until I finally
got it right but the point is I never
confused that he didn't like my first
few rounds with my value I was learning
how to write a pitch and so it ended up
being a fantastic education I actually
formed a fantastic relationship with him
so bring a great attitude when you get
harsh advice and just keep trying again
cuz sometimes it's fun